MAN 1: Physically,
I am exhausted.
You've done everything
you wanted to do out here,
you've tried everything
in your mind to get
food, and have mostly failed.
MAN 2: Made it outside.
First time I've been outside
in four days, first time
I've put my pants on in three.
But I'm still I'm motivated,
I'm still here for a purpose,
and I still have
fight left in me.
MAN 1: At this
point I'm not sure
how long I can go like this.
I'll have to tell my wife, my
kids, even though daddy tried
his best, he couldn't do it.
MAN 2: I'm sorry
and I'm not sorry,
but the remainder
of the footage will
probably look a lot like this--
20-hour days of me laying
here becoming common.
MAN 1: And as much
and I'm trying
to keep my family in
mind and do it for them,
I'm starting to have
thoughts in my brain
that if my wife could
see me right now,
it would bring her to tears, and
she would beg me to come home.
[music playing]
[wind whistling]
[slow steady beeping]
[truck engine humming]
MAN 3: How you doing?
I've been better
I'm all right.
I'm just-- I'm just beaten down.
I've run all the
tread off my tires.
And I'm sitting in there looking
at my shelter, and I can't--
I can't lay in there
another night by myself,
and be freezing, and
hungry, and by myself.
I just couldn't do it anymore.
I mean, I may have hit my
limit about a week or so ago,
but I just kept trying
to dig in and think
about the goals I was here for.
And today I sunk to a low I
just didn't think I could pull
myself back out of this time.
And I know what I
really really need
is waiting for me on the
other side of the world,
and I just really want
to get back to that.
This is not how I
saw myself leaving,
but I'm not hanging my
head about anything.
I battled myself way further
than anybody thought I could.
I'm definitely not the
prototypical survivalist.
I'm that dude that
sits over in accounting
and does the spreadsheets.
I'm not the guy that goes out
in the wilderness for 56 days.
I achieved a great deal,
and I'm really proud of it.
The hardest thing
about this experience
was it's definitely
a battle of the mind.
I've spent a whole lot
of time in Patagonia
breaking down interior walls.
That's the reason that I
got out of there quickly.
Mongolia enhanced the
way I was when I came,
so when I came here now
I felt a lot more open.
I was a lot more
open in speaking,
open in my feelings,
and in the end where I
look at where I ended up,
I'm extremely happy.
I feel cleansed,
and new, and open,
and ready to go
back to my family
and show them a
different type of love.
[truck engine humming]